tonight on the new reality things have
really accelerated with wave 2. i would
be lying if i said i wasn't tired
a pandemic that started 10 months ago as
a sprint
is now a marathon so half the ice two
right now is covet
they're all on life support in one way
or the other how worried are you about
going into christmas and what might be
waiting for us on the other side of that
very like unequivocally very
[Music]
for us i mean nothing has stopped babies
don't wait for pandemics to finish the
maternity ward at this hospital
has its hands full i'm pregnant i have
copen and i'm about to give birth
what's gonna happen the following are a
list of things
that we will or will not do once this
pandemic is done
and yes one day this pandemic will be
done
hello and welcome to the new reality i'm
donna friesen
it's been almost a year since the world
health organization first reported a
cluster of cases of a mysterious illness
in wuhan china
days later a new virus was identified
and what no one knew then is how
all-consuming covid19 would become
it has changed everything lives lost and
livelihoods destroyed it's hoped
vaccines will eventually wipe it out but
for now the virus is still winning
tonight jeff semple goes back to the
front line back inside
the coved ward at humber river hospital
[Music]
as covid19 cases climb hospitals in
ontario have been ordered to prepare
for a surge some postponing surgeries
to make room for the second wave of
patients
but there are some procedures that
simply
won't wait
[Music]
for us i mean nothing has stopped babies
don't wait for pandemics to finish
the maternity ward at this toronto
hospital has its hands full
delivering corona babies as they're now
affectionately nicknamed
a new generation born into a pandemic
this situation for patients is a very
happy one but a very nerve-wracking
one so adding the pandemic on top of
that for people has been
very challenging daniela campreera is an
ob
gyn at humber river hospital it's
located smack in the middle of one of
the hardest hit
neighborhoods in the country and its
staff aren't taking any chances
when pregnant patients arrive even
before the delivery room
they're tested for covid19 including
those without symptoms
and the result can make an already scary
situation
downright terrifying it was shocking
just days before her due date
alexandra abril tested positive for
kovid 19.
now i'm pregnant and i have coveted and
i'm at the end of my term
and i'm about to give birth what's gonna
happen
five seconds super fast abril's
three-year-old son
elijah also tested positive and so
did her husband which meant he had to
quarantine away from his family
and wasn't allowed in the delivery room
it was tough like you know then not
knowing like
when i'll be able to see them on a
brill's final day of quarantine
her daughter was born as a precaution
the infant was also tested for the novel
coronavirus
injuring two swabs in her tiny nostrils
[Music]
fortunately the baby's results came back
negative
her dad hasn't met her yet her other
grandma has only seen her through
a window so it's like very very
different experience and
it's sad but at the same time i know
health-wise
and i don't want them to get sick
especially my newborn baby
during the first wave of the pandemic
abril's diagnosis
would have shaken hospital staff
infected mothers in some hospitals were
kept away from their newborns
for up to two weeks there was definitely
a lot more panic just because we didn't
know
as much about the virus but the evidence
now shows the virus
isn't spread through breastfeeding and
babies have proved
remarkably resilient i think as long as
mom
uses the proper precautions then you
know keeping mom and baby together
are the most important thing the first
time we were here in toronto's humber
river hospital
was back in the spring during the height
of the first wave
and what a difference 10 months can make
the hospital
looks even feels different staff
sounding a lot more confident and for
good reason
we're far more prepared on wave 2 and so
you don't actually
feel the same level of stress and
anxiety the head of emergency
leon rivlin says a big part of that
preparation
is protection ppe in the early days of
the pandemic
staff struggled with a shortage masks
had to be
signed out and carefully conserved but
no longer today they're both better
equipped
and better informed we've learned a lot
about the transmission of the virus
that's why you see me
wearing a face like a visor covering my
face
and and a mask because even with our
three-ply masks there's still a little
bit of viral transmission
hi i'm dr nimji i'm gonna scooch in here
what's up not much how are you we first
met dr taslim nimji
back in march the er physician in charge
of the hospital's pandemic response
was worried about herself and her staff
becoming infected and bringing the virus
home to their families
we're here putting ourselves in harm's
way for our patients which we are happy
and proud to do
but thankfully those fears haven't
materialized
in this hospital staff haven't gotten
sick says
ceo barb collins we've had some
transmission but the transmission has
not occurred in the hospital
for the most part largely the staff who
have become ill
have picked it up outside outside in the
toronto
area kovid 19 cases have climbed to
record highs
the start of the second wave saw mostly
younger patients
but nimji says those demographics are
changing
before her eyes it was a matter of time
for it to shift into that older
population
including a growing number of
middle-aged patients
in their 40s and 50s it completely
changed my life
this 53 year old has no underlying
health conditions
but says she woke up struggling to
breathe
feel sick
short of breath
it's been really hard
for me and my family as cases climb
again staff are worrying less about
infection
than exhaustion a pandemic that started
10 months ago as a sprint
is now a marathon i mean on a personal
note like how are you
doing i mean i was how are you feeling
at this point thanks for asking um i
i would be lying if i said i wasn't
tired um you know especially now as
things have really accelerated with wave
two it's not a you know it's not a five
day a week job it's again a seven day a
week job
um and so so fatigued um but hopeful
um because we have to be hopeful
it does wear on you because it never
goes away right and
each day brings a new potential covet
outbreak
dr michael gardum is no stranger to the
pressures of a public health emergency
he was on the front lines of the sars
outbreak in 2003
if there's lots of virus in the room got
caught with their pants certainly if you
have a lot of cases of flu out there
has given countless media interviews and
held a number of leadership positions
providing a calm hand in the storm
you know i still have a bit of ptsd post
sars and then there was the concerns
with uh
h1n1 in 2009 and then there were
concerns a few years ago about you know
ebola virus coming to canada
there was so much fear and when you're
the person who's advising on what to do
and you're in all those meetings and
you're speaking to people in the media
and you're getting hit with these waves
of fear that is exhausting there is an
unprecedented outbreak of ebola virus
occurring in west africa
and then to draw a very clear
distinction between what's happening
there and what could happen here
in canada you're trying to walk that
line between i want you to be
noticing this i want you to be somewhat
concerned about this but i don't want
you to panic about this
and it's often very hard to walk that
line so this is our
our kova 19 tile during the first wave
of kovid 19
gardem was chief of staff at humber
river hospital
and while he was saving lives the
pandemic
nearly claimed his own but not
from the virus
during a hospital shift back in may
garden suddenly
felt a pain in his chest as a physician
you spend your first 10 minutes running
through a list of things that this could
be in your head
and then thinking this can't possibly be
cardiac but as he stumbled into the
emergency ward
he realized that's exactly what it was
garden was having a heart attack caused
by a blockage in his left
anterior descending artery morbidly
nicknamed
the widow maker talk about access to
health care right you know i had a heart
attack
in the hospital and then you know they
treated me extremely quickly the day
before i was at my farm in prince edward
county
if it would have happened the day before
i i wouldn't be here
now seven months later garden a former
marathoner
has made a full recovery and
a life change in october
he his partner and their dogs packed up
and moved out of the big city
to the ocean on prince edward island the
level of chronic stress and anxiety
which i think was compounded
with the pandemic that was like a major
wake-up call for me
and i felt at that point i needed to
change gears in what i was doing he's
still working full-time
but like many of us these days he's
doing more of his work
remotely at 56 he says he has no
interest in retiring
and this is no time to back away from a
fight
i know that there's been some pushback
about using war analogies you know the
way i look at it is
that it's kind of like we're in 1944
right now
you sort of think that there you can see
an end to this uh
but it's not going to happen tomorrow
and we've got months of slog to get
there
and you can't stop if you stop
you're going to lose all of the things
that you've fought so hard to win
and back on the front lines he says the
greatest threat to that victory
is covid fatigue and christmas
how worried are you about going into
christmas and what might be waiting for
us on the other side of that very
like unequivocally very coming up
on the new reality half the ic right now
is covet
they're all on life support in one way
or the other after months of battling
an invisible enemy staff have found
novel ways
to fight back the team is quite
significant and each
part is very important we don't
completely understand it and i don't
think we'll
understand it until it's over doctors
point to the case of delroy
noble every night before i sleep i
look to the heavens and i pray after
two months in a coma he suddenly opened
his eyes
welcome back they're already exhausted
but no the second wave of covid19 cases
will keep coming
filling up the icu doctors and nurses do
learn more about this virus every day
and say seeing some of their sickest
patients survive
is what keeps them going here's jeff
semple again
after months of battling an invisible
enemy staff at toronto's humber river
hospital have found
novel ways to fight back i think what we
have learned is that we know how to
treat it better dr jamie spiegelman
works in the intensive care unit
where on this day a dozen covid patients
are fighting for their lives so half the
ic right now is coved
they're all on life support in one way
or the other so we're seeing outbreaks
and families and we're seeing that when
family members are visiting other family
members and putting those people at risk
because covet 19 can attack in different
ways
spiegelman has brought back up he's
flanked by a respiratory therapist
a physiotherapist a nutritionist a nurse
and a social worker to help with
emotional distress
made worse by visitor restrictions so
the team is quite significant and each
part is very important to get these
patients better we first met spiegelman
during the first
wave back in the spring so it's really a
very smart virus
and witnessed a very close call
one of his covid patients struggling to
breathe had to be intubated
a ventilator tube inserted into their
airway
but during the procedure the patient's
heart
[Music]
stopped
[Music]
spiegelman and his team performed chest
compressions
and ultimately saved her life
everything's good now she's stable
there's a difficult intubation
unfortunately it happens
whether you have covered or not in the
months since they've learned
to do things differently we know how to
treat them better on the respirator
including placing patients onto
ventilators later
or not at all where possible staff are
now relying on these pressurized systems
which deliver oxygen
up the nose instead of a tube down the
throat
[Music]
this 69 year old patient isn't getting
enough oxygen
so the team performs a delicate dance
carefully flipping him
onto his stomach increasing blood oxygen
and chances of survival patients also
regularly receive steroids such as
dexamethasone well dietitian denise
poirier provides vitamin d
and zinc someone has acute respiratory
distress syndrome there are certain
vitamins and minerals that are applied
but having said that because this is
such
a new thing it's a brand new virus
there's nothing
scientifically proven yet that any of
those that nutritional component is
is effective and that remains a common
refrain
despite all they've learned about the
virus there is still much
they don't know as i remember you
described this as a
very smart virus it's still smart like
we still don't unders
clearly do not understand how it works
how it affects the worst
we don't know why some people are
getting sicker than others we have no
idea yeah it's definitely multifactorial
but we
don't completely understand it and i
don't think we'll understand it until
it's over
doctors point to the case of delroy
noble
that's him back in may on a ventilator
in a coma
just 29 years old i think given his age
that he did
come to us with less co-morbidities
noble was overweight but otherwise
healthy he'd been working as a baggage
handler at pearson airport where it's
believed he became infected with covid19
back in march
noble's mother marlene was also sick but
with minor symptoms
when i spoke with the doctors and they
said mom
you have a real critical sound
that that sink me but i still never give
up
i every night before i sleep i look
to the heavens and i pray
so it's a lot of prayer went up for him
doctors didn't expect
noble would survive but in july after
two months in a coma
he suddenly opened his eyes
if you can hear me can you
blink twice until they call me and tell
me
that your son is is um
walking i said my son wake up
that's when i jumped i was sitting there
and i jump
here i cry okay
i remember waking up feeling extremely
tired
exhausted you know body was heavy
you know felt light-headed and i knew
immediately like man i
was went through something rough and the
road to recovery has also been
a rough ride noble spent two months
in rehab first it started off small just
you know
moving the hands seemed like um see if i
could move the legs and stuff like that
then it progressed into sitting up for
the first time which was a challenge
and then eventually progressed to you
know standing for the first time
his internal organs lungs kidneys and
liver
have mostly recovered but now nearly
eight months since he first became
sick he still relies on a walker and leg
braces when he goes outside
i wouldn't want to go far because i get
tired
tired relatively easily physically
struggling
but emotionally noble is remarkably
upbeat
playing with his nieces and showing no
interest in self-pity
i made it out in the end so that's all
that matters
he's hopeful for a full recovery but for
now just glad to be home
with his family and he's not the only
one
elijah do you want to say hi to sister
alexandra abril
the mother of two who was diagnosed with
covid19 just days before giving birth
is now finally home her three-year-old
son
also recovered and just completed his
quarantine
and so too has her husband after two
excruciating weeks apart he's finally
able to meet his newborn daughter
for the first time
2020 was a year full of terrible stories
but there were still some that managed
to find their way
to a happy ending and in this case
a new beginning
[Music]
coming up on the new reality the holiday
season is here
it hasn't been all bad this year but
it's been mostly bad
it's been pretty bad but let's look
forward
everyone will remember the holiday
season of 2020
the christmas of covid it's hard to be
all jolly and bright when we're told we
can't get together with anyone
but traditions won't just disappear
they'll just get set aside put in a box
with
all your other junk in the garage and
we'll bring it all back out next year
as stuart reynolds the man known as
brittlestar reminds us
there is plenty to look forward to
the holiday season is here it hasn't
been all bad this year
but it's been mostly bad
it's been pretty bad okay if 2020 were a
thing
it would be past gas in an elevator
that's stuck between floors
but let's look forward the following are
a list of things
not an exhaustive list obviously that we
will or will not do
once this pandemic is done and yes
one day this pandemic will be done
we will embrace each other with only
normal concern for cooties we will
gather with friends and family
and initially enjoy their company
tremendously
and then slowly be reminded of how
annoying they are
we will sit in cafes eat in restaurants
go to the cinema go to concerts
walk maskless with impunity
we will not tell anyone for at least a
year
to be patient we've done patient
we're very good at patient now patient
can
off should there be things we wish to do
or places
we wish to go or people we wish to see
within reason we will do
go to or see them and being patient can
go to hell
at least for a while being patient will
need to just be
patient have a taste of its own medicine
because one day this pandemic will be
over
until then
we'll be patient
and that is the new reality for this
week thanks for watching
[Music]
you